now that you've completed this 10-year
project of the book that you're
essentially going to retire from Show
Business and and do everything that you
ever wanted to do I think what's going
to happen is something's going to come
up for you I think something's going to
come up and you're gonna go you know I'm
gonna go work on that it's your nature
well I hope you're right but the reason
I wrote the book in my in the first
place was because I couldn't get two of
the movies I wanted to make how is that
possible like Clint Eastwood still
directs uh you talk about people who are
older but were great directors that you
couldn't get these movies made you You'
you've made some of the biggest movies
on the planet what who would who would
say no to you I don't know I don't
know uh I wanted to end my career with
playing Gypsy it's a role that as I got
older I was offered to play it on stage
uh Through The Years you know Julie
Stein wanted me to do it Arthur Lawrence
wanted me to do it
I said I'm not ready and I'm I'm not
ready to play it and
now because I wanted to direct it and I
could see the you know every
frame and just be in it Stephen stime
who I adored working with because that
was a very creative time in my life with
him we were both so open to change
things and make it new but his same song
but looking at them again and he was so
open to change it was incredible but he
wouldn't he said you either direct the
movie or you act in it but you can't do
both I mean but after Prince of Tides
and after that's right Yen I said did
you not like my the movies I no yeah I
like them but I think this role is too
difficult but that's not true as I wrote
I wrote a a synopsis of how every scene
would work when there are things in life
that you can't
have what it was very sad for me does
that apply to your career in the sense
that uh I I would Bank on you directing
another movie and starring in another
movie I uh I would I wouldn't star in
another movie too too much of a pain in
the ass you know to get your hair done
your makeup and N I don't I'm not but
directing I could direct another movie
and I have one but it's like my fourth
choice of a movie to direct it's
not the two I wanted to Direct One was
about Margaret borke White then it was
on television I wanted to uh do
Catherine the Great and then all of a
sudden somebody else did Katherine the
Great she was a fascinating character to
me I wanted to do a picture called
triangle about the Triangle shirt waste
fire that became on television and they
did a pretty good job so what was I
going to do with it I had a different
take on it because it was a triangle
love story as
well but I sometimes I just give up too
easily